[Music]
welcome back to the machine learning
street talk youtube channel
today is the first in a three-part
series
on the social dilemma this is the
netflix film
which according to them explores the
dangerous human impact of social
networking with
tech experts sounding the alarm on their
own creations
i think we take a slightly different
view netflix is famous for partisan
information
whether it's about veganism or politics
or goodness knows what else
it's been said that social media games
and deranges our attention
but should social media be regulated
certainly there were naysayers before
seat belts got introduced or before the
smoking ban and no one seriously
suggesting that we should turn the clock
back on that now
is this just the latest moral panic
could social media actually be a good
thing for our society
society is changing fast and it's too
late to put the genie back in the bottle
but some have argued that this film is
patronising paternalistic
sanctimonious and created by a bunch of
tech bros
in the show tonight we spoke about the
moral hypocrisy of the film
the road to hell is paved with good
intentions
how social media giants possibly know
everything about you
the addictive properties of social media
and also the differential consciousness
or the different
realities that people have when they log
into social media we talk about your
moral right to
self-determination and the monetization
on facebook
we also talk about this interesting
concept that they said that ai would
overcome our strengths and in many ways
it overcame our weaknesses
but there is this interesting conception
that people have of artificial
intelligence that's almost
anthropomorphic or embodied
and of course there's no such thing as
ai it's just very basic pattern
recognition but apparently it's been
enough to
derange our attention on social media we
talk about conspiracy theories and fake
news and polarization
we talk about how your short attention
span can easily be gamed by social media
is social media good for you and as andy
our guest tonight
is a cyber security expert we talk about
social engineering attacks and the
security of social media in general and
whether or not it's
safe to have your information in social
media and finally we talk about the
morality of retrospective judgment
whether in 20 years time you should be
morally accountable for things that you
did and were recorded in social media
anyway this is our machine learning
street talk tonight i hope you enjoyed
the episode because we had a lot of fun
making it
remember to like comment and subscribe
we love reading your comments
and we'll see you back next week welcome
back
to the machine learning street talk
youtube channel
now today we have a cyber security
professional andy smith and i'll
introduce andy in a minute
so next week we've got the founder of
the montreal ethics institute abby gupta
the following week we've got dr rebecca
roach senior lecturer and philosophy at
royal holloway
university of london and some of her
interests are in ethics and the theory
of friendship
now our special guest today is andy
smith he's a security professional
working in the corporate world
he's also got a youtube channel on cyber
security and
there's a great playlist that i've just
been looking on his channel called
attack detect
defend and some of the videos he's got
on there are com hijacking forced
authentication
abusing windows services path
interception
image file execution privilege
escalation of using windows
accessibility features it's really cool
actually andy's put a lot of effort in
into his youtube channel
he also covers the crinkle con security
festival and the sans holiday hack
but um anyway andy has particular
interest in ethics and digital trust
and he's a good mate of mine and we
often have lots of deep discussions
around ai ethics and governance and
security and so on
but also joining the show is is yannick
lightspeed culture but he'll be joining
any minute now
and of course we have one of our regular
staff members here
at machine learning street talk zack
jolst zach is a machine learning
research scientist at amazon web
services in seattle
and zac has his own youtube channel as
well which is the ai overlords channel
and you will need to subscribe to that
channel now today
we're talking about the social dilemma
film
the film touches on many issues and is
surprisingly elusive to articulate
one of the quotes in the film actually
is that there are only two industries
which calls it customers users the
software industry and the illegal drugs
industry
why do people use social media
recognition identity
self-presentation finding your tribe and
socializing
escapism maybe but what are the
negatives about social media
it's been said that it fractures our
reality and polarizes us politically
some have even described social media as
the cult industrial complex
the algorithms used might inadvertently
derange our attention
and addict us to the platform some have
said it's somewhat akin to the climate
change of culture
eroding the social fabric and debasing
our humanity
there's been an epidemic of teen
depression and self-harm
and suicides which have been potentially
linked to social media
there are implications for privacy and
social media has been referred to as
surveillance capitalism
does social media undermine democracy
and promote propaganda
some have said that social media
facilitates the spread of misinformation
and outrage as social media companies
become publishers
how should they define what information
should be censored
should social media be regulated the
monetary incentives are distorted by the
choice of advertising as the revenue
model
and does social media affect our agency
or of self-determination
has the technology become too persuasive
but it's not all doom and gloom is this
just a moral panic
i remember when people thought that
violent films were debasing our society
social media can help you find life
advice it can land you a job
it can help you build meaningful new
friendships online or find your tribe
you can use it to promote your business
or brand and possibly even
increase your productivity because you
can use it as a tool of temporary
relaxation and escapism
anyway this is our machine learning
street talk episode today
and zach and andy welcome to the show
thanks great a beard tim
thanks tim so um let's start with you
andy what was your take on the film
so straight off the bat just in terms of
how the film was presented and came
across
i felt myself a little bit on edge
throughout quite a lot of it
and that was down just to the manner of
which that film presented itself
it was very provocative i very
quickly got a feeling that it was
designed to
tug on certain emotional and
psychological parts of my brain
there was some imagery there some
graphics showing
puppetry and clearly that's quite an
emotive
image there was clearly the fictional
story
of the family in the film highlighting
obviously some of the the dangers of
social media and some of the the bad
side
to me it wasn't necessarily always clear
where
that fictional story stopped and
the factual documentary began
there were some very evocative quotes in
there and
you mentioned one in the introduction
there tim
around only two industries refer
to people as users the drugs industry
and the software industry
again very very emotive and i think that
emotive
aim was misguided for me
personally as a viewer because whenever
i
feel like any activity is tugging on my
emotions
or tugging on some of those
psychological
cues in my brain it makes me ask why
and i felt like that devalued the
message of the film
for me i'm a very logical person a very
factual person
and so for me it made me wonder how fair
is this film going to be because most of
the time when you see
that type of material elsewhere on the
internet and
funnily enough elsewhere on social media
it's because it's trying to push an
agenda
so i found it a little ironic that the
way this film came across
was using some of those same techniques
and sneaky ways of manipulation
that they in the film actually go on to
criticize
that is really interesting because the
film talks about persuasive technology
and you could just argue that this is a
moral panic we've had the advertising
industry for 80 years or so and the
whole point of that industry is to
create uninformed consumers that make
irrational
decisions and in the film they talked
about this kind of
almost game theoretical adversarial
attack that these algorithms used to
manipulate your behavior but as you say
it's really interesting that the film
was also presented in
quite a manipulative way zack what was
your take classic
yeah andy almost took the words out of
my mouth that's exactly what i wanted to
say that
to me the most striking part of the film
was the irony
that they were perpetrating the same
sorts of
moral ambiguities that they were calling
out in these other platforms
i think that the entertainment industry
has a lot of the same incentives as the
advertising industry
like they're trying to capture your
attention they're trying to go viral
they want you to talk about it they want
you to engage with it
and one really great strategy for doing
that is
getting people triggered on their deep
seated
values and making them feel emotional
and scared
and panicked and all those things and
this film exactly did that and
to me it immediately put me on guard to
start playing devil's advocate so
i think maybe because people like us
have a little more familiarity with
these technologies because we work in
the industry or adjacent to it
but they were trying to target people
presumably that don't have much
information and i think
had they taken really dry objective
approach it maybe
wouldn't have captured as many people so
in some sense
like if their objective is to raise
awareness and to
get people really thinking about it then
perhaps the
end justifies the means but that's a
very slippery slope so i think that
itself is a very interesting question
and it directly translates to what
they're trying to
think about in terms of these social
media platforms and what their moral
obligations are and what's
in bounds and out of bounds and all that
stuff that's super interesting
because you made the difference between
the entertainment industry and the
advertising industry
and in entertainment if you go and speak
to a public speaking coach now
the coach will tell you to tell stories
and to make it
resonate with people and to hang on
people's emotions and so on
netflix do that as well because they
they have such a high degree of
personalization they also do a b testing
and they show you
personalized thumbnails and maybe in
some meta sense they also test different
styles of content and the ones which are
successful they they produce in a way
netflix are doing exactly the same thing
they might say we're going to introduce
this particular feature
and we're going to make it available to
some people and not others
yeah it reminds me of an anecdote and i
don't know if this is
how true this is but uh it was that the
the way the house of cards
series came about was that netflix
learned that
it's people liked political dramas that
it liked
things directed by david fincher and it
liked kevin spacey
and it like basically spit out the
formula for the show and then that they
did that so i don't know if that's true
but i would be surprised if they didn't
take advantage of all that user data
to guide their decisions of the content
they make and especially
targeting to the people based on that's
obvious
recommendation engine 101 they even had
the netflix challenge you're supposed to
do these sorts of things
so we know that they're targeting
content based on
behavior on the platform exactly and
netflix is interactive
and as you say they are optimizing for
engagement
in exactly the same way so the goals on
facebook are engagement growth and
advertising
and on netflix presumably it's exactly
the same without the advertising
but anyway yannick lightspeed culture
has just joined us and just to fill you
in uh
yannick andy led by saying that he was a
little bit
jarred by the experience of the film
because it was just as persuasive and
almost as bad as the thing that they
were talking about and
and then zach came in and said basically
there's very little difference between
the
advertising industry and the
entertainment industry they're all
trying to
derange your attention so what was your
take yannick yeah ultimately
it's an attention economy right since a
few
years we have never been bored again
like i remember the experience of
boredom from my childhood
i don't ever i think i was never bored
in the last five years and this might be
because i've
grown up a little and have more stuff to
do more stuff to think about but also
because
all our time is filled and so ultimately
uh
attention has become the sparse good and
i agree like the entertainment industry
as well as the advertisement industry
they're all after this
attention of course they're going to uh
find some hacks in that of course humans
aren't perfect
you're going to find some hacks in that
and and that's just my overarching
thought and that
it's yeah it's fundamentally the way
we are right now our attention is
limited good but now
it's mediated through facebook so that
seems to be quite a big step
yeah of course and i i think everyone
kind of feels the same
in that we're all uneasy that these
two or three or four companies hold
in their hands hold our attention
collectively in their hands
and they could potentially manipulate
that
to to do all cut all sorts of things and
there's multiple takes here the biggest
one i feel is that
they cannot be infinitely evil because
ultimately they're bound by let's say
the market
and and ultimately they
run a free service most of these
companies do except netflix let's say
but
facebook and all these advertisement
driven they're on a free service
and they're banking on these ads and i
always think that people are more greedy
than they are evil
at least most people are they would
rather enrich themselves
a lot rather than put everyone else down
if they have the choice so they'd rather
take the most money in an unbiased way
than the nefarious and be like
i'm going to grab your attention at
least that's
i see that the potential and the
uneasiness we have with all of this
monopolizing of attention but on the
other hand you have to think about that
these companies
are pulled by a lot of forces that are
to a large part out of their control and
kind of
regulate the thing a bit interesting one
lady in the film made a particularly
hyperbolic statement she said that it's
a marketplace which trades in human
futures
and everything you do is monitored they
know if you're depressed if you're
introverted they know your personality
type
there's almost no supervision they they
know how long you're looking at the
photos they know if you're lonely
is that just hyperbole andy i guess
i i don't work for the facebooks so i
couldn't tell you
if they could determine whether i'm
happy or sad on a given day i find it
a little bit of a stretch for that
determination to
really be that effective and mainly it
comes down to
i think the each individual's use of
those platforms
i personally am not a big social media
user i
i don't really post a huge amount of
stuff so
the amount of information that various
social media companies have on me to
make decisions about me
frankly it goes to show in the sorts of
adverts that i see
that are very very rarely related to the
things i care about so
clearly i'm doing something good in
terms of
not giving away those crucial nuggets of
information
and i think that is something that maybe
the film
tries to put across in
trying to educate the viewer on
the the motivations and some of the
tactics
used by not only the social media
companies themselves
but also the advertisers and other users
of
the social media platforms in order to
grab our attention
and change our minds about things and
make us act in ways that
they would find advantageous because
and i think this is one of the the
quotes in is that someone in the field
mentioned
by equipping people with the knowledge
about how they are being abused or being
attacked by these platforms
it gives those same people the ability
to be alert
and to be defensive against that and i
think
maybe us on the call here i think we
mentioned earlier
we're probably more familiar with these
things already so we're aware of them
and we can take steps to maybe not give
away quite so much personal information
or and cautious about what we share or
just be very cognizant that the messages
that we're showing on our screens
are maybe not always completely what
they seem and maybe that yeah that's the
purpose of the film
i said before i don't think the film
worked for me but for others who
are potentially more easily
swayed in this particular area because
they know less about the technology
maybe this film did help to educate them
on the technology and the motivations
and help make them better equipped to
defend themselves against those kind of
tactics in the future
but as you said the same tactics to tell
the message which was a little bit
ironic
but you did say something interesting
which is it possible for us to build an
immunity to this can we inoculate
ourselves against this
and a lot of this it falls back on our
free will
should we be allowed to gamble or take
drugs
because some people can recreationally
enjoy these things but they can still
pull themselves
back out of it some people clearly
develop um
a problem with addiction on these
platforms
what do you think zach yeah very
interesting question
i think the analogy of addiction and
drugs is a pretty good one
because i'm talking to a friend of mine
on a related topic of
content moderation on facebook and the
ethics of that and he's very much on the
kind of libertarian freedom first thing
but
you do have these questions if someone
wants to see conspiracy related
content who are we to say no right
because
this is uh presumably a free society and
the internet and all that stuff
but on the other hand we just because
people want heroin we don't let them
have access to it
as much as they want because the so
there's like a line somewhere and the
question is where should it be drawn
and there's a spectrum right there's not
like an obvious answer to that
and i think when there's addiction
involved when there's harm
that can be traced back to these sorts
of things
then it raises serious questions but the
answers are not at all obvious of
how we draw this line for such a huge
spectrum of content like
some of the easy ones are like we don't
want our platform to
help spread terrorism rhetoric and
propaganda like
that one's pretty well slam dunk they
also make a determination on
like nudity and pornography that they've
decided that's not the type of content
they want on their platforms
and i think most people would agree that
they should have the right to be able to
make that determination
but then when you're talking about
whether a political statement is
misleading
or harmful like it gets really squishy
there
and i don't know who should be in charge
if anyone for
making those sorts of calls because it
it's so dangerous
to give that sort of power to people and
i think even the examples you gave there
of
things that were obviously bad and
undesirable on a platform
terrorism one man's terrorist is another
man's freedom fighter how do you decide
who is the terrorist and who is the
freedom fighter
nudity what about art there's many
aspects of art that have nudism in them
where do you draw the line
i think each individual will draw the
line in
a different place and as one of the
fundamental challenges that
our society has and by extension the
social media companies is
where do you draw that line and to your
point zach
who even has the authority to draw that
line who do we want to have that power
because
that is quite a big power it's one thing
where you draw the line between
what is art and what is nudity but the
line you draw between
what is terrorism versus what is an
activist or a freedom fighter
that has obviously far more significant
consequences right
there was a wonderful quote in the film
um the data scientist ladies
said that the best proxy for truth at
the moment is a human clique
they have no idea of knowing what is
true and what is false
as a separate thing we we seem to be
moving into an ultra relativist idea now
that
there is no such thing as objective
truth and that reality is constructed
from language and then by structures of
power in society and so on so
in a way facebook is the manifestation
of that because it's the ultimate
atomized reality it's your own reality
it's a fractured or differential reality
everyone who logs into facebook sees
their own
reality yeah one of my favorite quotes
from the film
was a guy say it feels like the entire
world has gone crazy
but i can't tell whether this is an
artifact of
this system where like really nothing
has changed and it's just surfacing the
stuff that makes me feel like it's gone
crazy
or perhaps it actually has gone crazy
and something's new here and
the the really scary part is you can't
tell the difference right
because for me i have such a hard time
telling
the difference between trying to keep my
thumb on the pulse of
what society at large thinks about
particular topics
because i find that like uh i'll have
some narrative in my head that i
that makes sense to me and then i'll
read something that sort of challenges
that and then i'll start investigating
that thread of what the devil's advocate
piece and then it seems
every time i sign into youtube or
whatever where i was researching these
things
now i'm just like flooded with more
content on those threads
so i don't know if there's been a
pendulum starting to shift
with the general consensus of society or
whether this is just
targeting and the fact that you're in
the middle of this whirlpool and can't
tell the difference
i i don't know how to solve that as a
individual
yeah i feel this this is especially the
topic
of these filter bubbles i think that's
it's been around for
10 years or so or more but i think it
becomes more and more pronounced as just
you have to actively go out
and try to disconfirm your story
i feel that is the thing that none of
these
companies do for you because it's just
not profitable
right because you get your cognitive
dissonance and so on
i i think it's still possible that you
can get a feeling for what's going on by
simply you go out and you
really try to make the case against
yourself
and that's hard because you are you and
you can't want something to be true
but still you go and you try and at some
sometimes you find something where
you'll be like yeah maybe i was wrong
and
other times you're more than not you're
probably right because you are you and
you're the smartest person ever
but i i feel you have to actively do
this
and you are not encouraged by any of
these
attention economy driven companies to do
that so
as a libertarian and i feel that the
liber it's interesting because
in this point i feel libertarians are
arguing against libertarians
because you have the libertarians who
say on facebook everything
who's to say what's nudity and what's
not so and it's very dangerous
what you said right it's very dangerous
to give someone that power and the other
libertarians say facebook is a private
company they can do
whatever they want to see just make your
own facebook it's it's in a bizarre way
it's like free market enthusiasts versus
ultra free market enthusiasts
i yeah i don't know what to say to that
i think janet you call out a really cool
point there around
we have to go out of our way in order to
disprove ourselves in order to arrive
at what is actually the truth and yeah
the various social media platforms do
very little if
anything to actually force that upon you
but in their defense if we take social
media companies out of this a second
when it comes to newspapers or
tv shows or news channels or
conversations that you have
with your mates down the pub how often
do you go out of your way in those
situations to
try and uh play devil's advocate and uh
dissuade yourself around your opinions
it's just not a natural thing that we do
as humans
and i think that's where these social
media platforms actually have
a great possibility to bring
that depth of different perspective to
us
in a way that probably isn't available
in many other mechanisms of social
interaction
or media they have this amazing ability
that they could do that
but they aren't at the moment how would
users
actually react to that is another big
question mark
i don't know but i think that's a power
that is not being utilized and it should
be
how much self-determination do you think
we actually have because one of the
wonderful things
about youtube in particular is you can
just start
looking at videos of i don't know dogs
or machine learning or something
and it learns so quickly and my youtube
feed i'm almost embarrassed to show
other people because it's a scary
representation of me i mean clearly it's
i see it as an invasion of my privacy in
many ways so
it's so easy for people to break out of
that basin of attraction if they want to
but the thing is people don't because
there is that little bit of cognitive
dissonance as yannick
called it out and because they are
myopically optimizing on this objective
which is
engagement or growth or advertising
there's no incentive really for them to
help people break out of that basin of
attraction yeah
i feel like the film touched on the ad
thing but a lot of them are like
in the very beginning of the film they
asked them well what's the core problem
and maybe it was just crafty editing but
it was just like a bunch of people
looking up and thinking
trying like grasping at straws but i
think very clearly
unless i'm being overly simplistic the
problem is the ad model
it's that it netflix
is trying to basically make you happy
but netflix isn't paid more if you watch
more
they're paid based on subscriptions so
whether you watch an hour a day
or 10 hours a day they don't really care
actually they might even prefer you to
watch
an hour a day right because it's less
strain on their infrastructure and all
that stuff
whereas these ad driven businesses
they're incentivized to get you as much
and as long
as possible they want as many hours of
your day as they possibly can
and to me that's where the incentives
really start breaking down it also
the incentives for micro targeting are
baked in with the advertising model it's
these are out of one million people
these are one the one thousand that
bought this thing from me this widget
so they give me more people like this
and then they build out all the
infrastructure for micro targeting so
to me that's like the core problem that
there's these incentives
they built this technology to satisfy
those and then
those technologies can be weaponized for
other purposes
aside from advertising political
manipulation so on and so forth
and then that's where it gets like
really sketchy but i i don't know they
didn't spend much time
talking about if there are alternatives
to the ad model
to finance these platforms or whether
there's a way to tweak it
so that the incentives are aligned
slightly differently
the problem is people don't want to pay
for anything
and at the end of the film they were
almost taking a step towards having a go
at capitalism
they said that's because of the profit
motive and unfortunately
if you take this argument to its extreme
it will just say well it's immoral for
companies to make profit
so what do you do because whenever you
have some kind of objective you will
always have perverse incentives and
you'll have
shortcuts and so on but they said
something interesting in the film
they said that we thought that ai would
overwhelm human strengths
but it actually undermined our
vulnerabilities
it says nothing but they were saying via
distraction
and using our dopamine and reward
systems and we don't have stopping
cues the technology never stops talking
to us and we need
social approval and we can only hold a
certain number of things in our working
memory and
there's a currency of likes and we want
as many likes as possible and so on so
um these are very human features that
they are undermining using this almost
game theoretical adversarial attack
on our brain you can just reframe it as
saying it's overwhelming our strength to
to control ourselves you can frame it
wherever you want
yeah i gotta say i don't think the
algorithms are really that smart
i don't think they are intentionally
undermining
our abilities the algorithms are pretty
dumb
i think that was his point though he's
saying that we haven't actually
developed ai
the algorithms are just looking at
really simple statistical patterns
between actions on on the system and
things that we've done before
and just those simple patterns are
enough to undermine us and manipulate
us yeah quite possibly i think it
depends on the nature of the
content as well and how much involvement
there is from
human beings in that process so
again in the film the algorithm was
portrayed as being three guys who are
like pressing buttons and turning levers
and all of this kind of thing
and see again very emotive as if there's
a conscious being that is
tuned into you as an individual that is
playing you
but it's really not that smart and sure
if you then add in a bunch of humans
that have
ulterior or malicious motives then
i think they can use those algorithms in
a
negative way but the algorithms
themselves are completely
agnostic to the information that they're
processing
but that's the beauty of it that the
algorithms are dumb but it's like death
by a thousand cuts because when you have
the liquidity of millions of people
using
social media then they gave the example
you could be a foreign hostile
government
and you don't need to send your planes
and bombers over to the states anymore
facebook actually gives you the tools
you can log into their platform and
you can do advertising and you can
persuade people
from home without having to do anything
again it's like where do you draw the
line
so advertising toothpaste is fine but
advertising regime change is clearly not
great
and there's a whole gray messy area in
between right
let's talk a little bit about some of
the conspiracy theories on there right
so
uh there are things like chemtrails and
pizzagate and silver solution and qa
none and so on and there's quite an
interesting thing
i call it the package deal concept so i
think facebook learns that if you like
one conspiracy theory you're quite
likely to
subscribe to other ones as well and it's
almost like a gateway
isn't it so you you just get drawn into
this world of misinformation and
conspiracy
is that just because these people are
feeble-minded or are they being
manipulated well i remember youtube in
the early days it was awesome
like it was nazis had ufos and
all types of stuff it was great and and
yeah yeah once you watched one
all these others popped up and it was
fantastic but it was not like i'm
i'm now running around saying birds
aren't real or something like birds
aren't real but all the other conspiracy
theories are clearly
i can do the same thing where it's where
is it entertainment because
it's entertainment where is it a free
market of ideas because
you're very quick to label something as
a conspiracy theory
once the consensus is that we need to
weed out the conspiracy theories that
once we as humanity we come together and
be like
yeah okay even if it's cool for
entertainment they're actually harmful
so
no more conspiracy theories and then as
soon as you don't like something
you'll be like conspiracy theory and
then you have it's the same with like
fake news like ooh fake news okay so you
had situations
where it was like clearly a problem on
facebook and whatnot people would just
make up news stories like just straight
make them up to just you to
clearly target some kind of political
sub group
who's like this type of ethnic person
with this job
kills this other type his children from
this other type of person and laughed
and burned
whatever symbol and that's okay fake
news so we agree
let's weed out fakeness but now you can
call whatever you don't like
fake news so because this is a
phenomenon
that in the last five years i've
encountered so often it's like we agree
something is bad
we'll just redefine something else
and then conflate it and we already
agree it's bad so again
it's so hard but that's my yeah my take
on how do you define all these things
just quickly on that there's always been
an overton window so
we've accepted that holocaust denial is
absolutely unacceptable
but now it appears as if for example if
you're a nazi
you should be thrown off the platform
there's no question but
the overton window seems to be so small
now
that lots of opinions which would have
been completely
acceptable five or ten years ago would
now
get you thrown off the platform i don't
know what an overton window is but
just try and piece it all together
basically yeah it says the frame of
acceptable discourse
okay so yeah it seems like it's just so
polarized right now and i don't know if
this is
a causal link back to the social media
or or what
actually explains the polarization in
our society right now but at least in
america
it's like there's this frame of things
you can say and you're part of the tribe
in anything you say that's not part of
that you're a bigot
or you're a snowflake or whatever it is
on the other side
and it's just like these different
definitions and then they're online on
the same platform
and whenever they do interact it's just
very volatile and uh
that's what keeps me up at night and i
don't know how to get out of that
but to me that's the biggest concern is
the polarization that may or may not be
derived
from these platforms and these
incentives that uh it seems to just be
getting worse with no end in sight
yeah i'd agree i i've seen that in a
couple of cases where
a group of individuals are talking about
a particular topic
and they all generally broadly agree
with that topic
but one person has said something that
is just
slightly not aligned to the gospel view
of this almost religious like opinion
on a particular topic and that
individual gets ostracized
by the very people who they are broadly
aligned with
it is quite scary when seeing this play
out in some
threads online it's am i missing
something here it really is scary i
agree
i think we come to a common theme here
and that is
just this kind of and we we had it with
the ad model
and with these filter bubbles and that
is
clearly people forget
more and more that there is a world
outside of their sphere of interest
like i i feel more and more people
somehow forget that there are people
that think different from them
that are not completely stupid right
like it's possible to think to have
different opinions than you have
while also being fairly rational but you
simply make different
trade-offs on core values let's say and
that
i feel that gets forgotten more and more
so our question should be
can we find a way to ideally to
monetize this engaging people with these
different points of views because
ultimately that's going to be the only
way we can achieve it if there's a way
to monetize this right some of these
people will say
that a rationality and the enlightenment
values and science are meta narratives
and they don't really exist so it's
quite difficult to
screw this it's rude it's quite
difficult to talk to these people these
people
are clearly people that think something
else that i think that are clearly
dumb yes so i think
what's interesting is that if you
go into any detail about a topic and
you're like
actually willing to engage on having a
dialogue and exploring the logic
on almost any topic you can find
reasonable people on both sides
but where that often gets lost is that
whether you have 144 characters or
whatever it is there's just no nuance
and there's no room for like actually
talking about
what's underneath the surface level and
i think that has driven people to have
these one answers for every question
it's oh free markets is the answer to
everything or racism or systemic
whatever is like causing all of
society's problems and it's like
this dogmatic or ideologue
type behavior of this very simple
explanation for the world but the world
is not
simple super complicated and maybe
there's this
adverse causal impact of life we've been
inundated with so much information
that our feeble human mind is not
capable of dealing with it so it like
reverts back to these very simple
explanations
but whatever the case may be somehow i
think
if you could bring nuance and long-form
discussions back into it
then you can see like all right well
there's actually people that disagree
with me
but they have valid points and maybe at
the end of the day we still disagree
but i can at least recognize that
they're not hateful bigots
we just happen to disagree and that's
okay and then we like figure out the
right policy
from there but i i i don't know how to
get that into twitter for instance
yeah ain't no one got time for that
though aren't they
it it comes kind of back to that
psychological thing
where we have this really short
attention span i i even noticed myself
doing this
i'll maybe open up twitter i'll scroll
through a few things and i'll find
myself just just scrolling i'm not
really seeing much
and suddenly it just there'll be a
picture or something that jumps out at
me it clearly
triggers a neuron in my primitive brain
that causes me to stop it and look at it
we we're not built for having that
detailed discussion
unless we're like really prepared for it
you know we're going to sit down we're
going to carve out a certain
hour of the day to challenge ourselves
mentally
and i guess most people just don't want
to do that they'd much rather turn on
the netflix and chill out after the end
of a busy day
in a sense you're confirming the
findings of the film which is that
our attention span is decreasing and we
need to hold our attention
because it's exploration versus
exploitation sometimes things need to
get a little bit worse before they get
better
we commit to a relationship through hard
times and good times but now
we have tinder and now we have
censorship by concision if you can't fit
it into 140 characters then you can't
learn anything
so what we're doing is we're making it
very difficult for people to
discover something new because it's so
easy for them
to find their own differential reality
and the path of least resistance is
going to be such that they always just
find their own bubble of information
that there's no reason whatsoever for
them to
actually explore and connect with people
that they don't agree with
you need to have a curious mind and i
know i feel like i personally have a
curious mind i've got the mind of a
hacker after all i like to explore
things i like to
to try and find the flaws and the gaps
and things but hey
that's just me and i know obviously
everyone's different in terms of their
just their personality but you still
have an attention span which hasn't been
eroded yet
it depends on the time of day hey if i'm
having a quick school through a social
media
whilst i'm waiting for the kettle to
boil that's different to
hey i'm sitting down and i want to find
out about certain information
i wonder if it's back when facebook for
instance started
it was like the college networks and you
would look at
your friends and your ex-girlfriend or
whatever and
it was very much social but but now it
seems like twitter and
i don't have a facebook account these
days but i assume it's the same where
it's like
your leisure activity when you're
sitting on the couch
isn't like this innocent
sort of information but it's like stuff
that's triggering you on social issues
and it's like this was supposed to be my
leisure time but now i find myself like
all wound up and wanting to argue
i don't know what explains that shift
but maybe that's
sort of a core problem used is like this
i'm not in the mindset for deep thought
i'm just trying to
pass a few minutes while i'm sitting on
the couch but now i'm being triggered by
all this like really engaging stuff
but maybe a lot of people enjoy
looking at facebook they love looking at
the cat videos
it's a little bit like we judge people
for gambling how could they possibly
enjoy gambling this is only bad for them
they don't know what's good for them we
should stop them from gambling
i want to talk a little bit about the
depression so they had jonathan hate
on the show and i read his book called
the coddling of the american mind which
i thought was a wonderful read actually
and he says that we've got a whole
generation that's more anxious and more
fragile and more
depressed they're having less romantic
interactions
less driving licenses he thinks there's
a real change in a generation and
gen z got on social media during middle
school
and he says that the pattern points to
social media as far as i'm aware there
isn't actually any evidence for that
whatsoever but
certainly if you look at the correlation
on the graph it certainly seems to be
correlated with mobile phone usage and
social media
and there are some statistics so suicide
a 10 to 14 year olds up 151
15 to 19 up 70 self-harm up 189
for 10 to 14 year old girl since 2009.
so
it doesn't look good does it yeah it
probably also correlates with the s p
500 or something
like there's so many time-based signals
that could correlate with it
it's hard to but i'm sure there's also
been studies i would be more surprised
than not if there wasn't some connection
between
a lot of social media usage and
depression or something like that but
i'm just not familiar with that
literature yeah there's this this whole
other thing in that we've been talking
about
social media as first of all it's this
ad driven thing where it tries to
maximize your engagement
and now about there are things on there
that trigger you
but this i i feel comes back to the
actual
originally intended use of social media
namely
that you share things with your friends
and even that
right it's often people who make that
connection which
i i also don't know how much i agree
with this connection between
people are more depressed and so on and
social media that's actually because
they're using it correctly their friends
share
things that are cool and you're just not
again your private brain is not capable
of handling
all these other people doing all this
cool stuff and you're just
here you haven't cleaned the toilet in a
while and
you've eaten like three cheetos already
and
so so it's i feel it's an entirely even
an entirely different issue
than misuse this is actually just use
yeah but that's an interesting argument
though because you're saying it's almost
like the market efficiency
you're saying that this is a natural
phenomenon that when people have more
awareness of the world around them
they get compressed but it's not
necessarily a bad thing it's just
progress
oh it's it's clearly a bad thing for the
people it's just that
they are they are more aware
you see a hundred photos of people doing
cool things
but you forget that you have a thousand
friends and 900 of them
don't post photos but the implication is
there are
concentric circles of awareness so
clearly if we were aware of
all of the horrible things going on in
syria at the moment that would
annoy us we have concentric circles of
moral obligation i think it was um
peter singer who had this idea we only
really care about what's happening in
our immediate family and our friends and
so on
and facebook just increases the the
efficiency of our awareness bubble
but the implication is that we should
just start meditating and just
completely
have the blinkers on and not pay
attention to anything that goes on in
the world
otherwise we're going to be horribly
depressed
i guess the problem is that your
awareness is linear
you spend double the amount of time you
can process double the information
but the space of things that you can
consider
is multi-dimensional space so it's a
volume and that doesn't fit
you can't increase you can't say okay
here is all my interests i'm going to
engage with
all the interests that are next to my
interests
because that grows exponentially and you
only have linear time so
it's never possible i think the entire
discussion about these social media
companies is that they
have the power to direct this linear
attention into one particular direction
of that interest of an interest so my
my question would be is the potential
solution to this
more anonymity because
let's say with the ad model if you have
more anonymity
online it makes it less likely for for
people to target you there are models
where
you can explicitly say who can target
you and you who can't
in terms of free speech if you have ever
been to 4chan
it's not a nice place it's not it's not
a happy place
but certainly it's a free speech place
you can find the most horrible
ideas there but at least you can find
them and also
to yeah i don't know how to the social
media aspect i guess anonymity isn't
really helpful there but for all of the
other problems
i would postulate that a bit more
anonymity online
might be a good solution what's the
counter
to this i don't think it matters if
you're anonymous or not
you can be an anonymous potato and you
start
taking action in the system and it will
still
put you into a bucket of behavior but on
the 4chan for you a free speech
fundamentalist do you think that
sunlight is the best disinfectant for
bad ideas or
do you think we should draw lines
i recognize there are good arguments
against it but that was that would just
be my my postulation that
maybe a bit more anonymity is a good
thing
in these cases because it's also
personal
i guess the challenge with the anonymity
though is that then there
is less information about users for
those
ads to be targeted right and at the end
of the day if we're still
going to continue with a ad based model
and advertiser is going to be less
willing to
pay a certain amount per impression if
that
impression is less targeted towards a
particular demographic that they're
interested in
yeah you could take away some of that
anonymity but is that going to
i just wonder what sort of adverse
effect is that going to have
on that advertising model are we going
to see more ads
are we going to see other mechanisms of
tracking individuals
i don't know just like to challenge that
a tiny bit because i don't think
so andy smith the person i don't think
that's even relevant in their targeting
and
the next level is demographic style
information i don't think that's
relevant either
the highest specificity information
about you is your attentional metadata
and as i said you could be an anonymous
potato it doesn't matter who you are
what matters is that they can project
you into some
geometric space which represents your
interests in lots of different
dimensions so
they don't need to know who you are but
they can still target you they can
derange your attention
and they can make you buy things and
waste time on the platform
sure i guess it comes back to yannick
what your kind of definition of
anonymous was there
is it in terms of hey there's a identity
that knows everything about me apart
from who i
am that's one flavor of being anonymous
or is it a case of
every single interaction i have with a
social media platform
is effectively created in its own almost
like bubble its own identity shell
and therefore there is no connected
metadata to that
yeah i don't know maybe i i know there
are all these models
i see your point obviously the market
force right now is clearly in the
direction of
the more the advertiser knows about you
that the
the more they like it the more they're
going to pay for it and
i see where the pull is it it just if we
want to solve this problem we have to
think about
ways to make money in different
in a different route i can't imagine
this problem is going to be solved in
any other way
because what do you want to do regulate
stuff
that's never going to work we know that
that is not going to work
so yeah yeah i'm not sure
you say that but a number of the social
media companies are actually actively
asking for
government regulation because i think
they've reached the point where they
realize
they don't want to be the ones
accountable for making some of these big
decisions around hey
where do we draw that line between
what's acceptable and what's not so
they're almost asking for that
regulation right
the cynical libertarian would say that
if you have a monopoly you want
the government to regulate you because
that makes it
much harder for your competitors to
catch up because market entry has just
become impossible
because you'd have to comply with all
the regulations
that's what i would say
i actually have the question for for you
andy i just hear things right
and i hear things that nowadays
let's say the ultra classic when i hack
into the system
like this sql injection whatnot is
so such a small part of the security job
and actually the biggest vulnerability
are the people or is phishing is social
engineering attacks and so on
what kind of threat level do you give
these social media
platforms imagine if i could ultra
target
these people i i would know aha i'm
going to target the
whatever the security officer of this
particular company
and i'm going to make that guy or a
woman like really tired for a week
and then or i'm going to show them
some sort of fake ads for the beliefs
how much of a threat do you think this
is
to legitimate security of systems
so that's an interesting concept of
attacking
from using a social media platform as
effectively an advertiser to inject
content to
individuals absolutely
social media is one of the big dangers
you're absolutely right humans
are one of the the weakest links
when it comes to cyber security because
we build our computer systems for people
to use them
and so we trust that if
if andy smith logs into a system then
andy is allowed to do all these
different things
the problem comes if andy smith is
foolish and clicks on a link and
a hacker's unable to get his username
and password and then
as far as the system is concerned it's
just serving all those normal requests
for what it thinks is andy smith but of
course it's it's a hacker
and social media is a great way to
find out information about an individual
so that could be to
make a fishing campaign a lot more uh
convincing
so maybe andy likes i don't know is we
really like cycling so a good fishing
campaign might be
oh hey andy there's uh we've got a
discount on
uh high range bikes uh 20 discount just
for you or something along these lines
i'm more like to click on them we also
see
quite a lot of activity on
linkedin obviously linkedin being the
the social media platform for
business people and i think a lot of
people
perceive it as a safer place because
it's
business it's very formal there's no
city cat videos on linkedin so it must
be safe but there are
many very funded and very capable
adversaries that are using wesley
creating fake linkedin profiles to
connect with individuals
to find out okay who are you connected
to and so again they can use that
information
to increase the likelihood of a phishing
email being successful because
instead of a phishing email coming from
some random person that you've never
heard of
it comes from oh actually your boss
because
you've through you've given away your
linkedin or giving away your
a connection to your linkedin profile
someone can see who your boss is
so yeah absolutely we do quite a lot of
activities in
in the areas where i work to try and
educate people around good social media
use
we even undertake some digital
footprinting activities
where we will as ethical hackers
basically go out and do some searches on
social media sites to try and find the
exact information
that hackers will try and find and then
play it back to these individuals
yeah these particularly kind of high net
worth individuals or executives
just to show them hey this is the sort
of stuff that is very easy for attackers
to
present to you actually be on the
lookout for it it's not that often
that a attack will target
the the terminal target of a particular
attack straight off
because that individual or that company
or that system
is likely to be quite high value and
therefore defended
so we actually see quite a lot of
attacks start off by targeting
for lower seniority employees so maybe
just a generic accounts processing
person
who you know at a fairly low rung in an
organization
and through the compromise of that
individual
that's the the first foot in the door
for then an attacker to then expand
outwards
to move laterally either through
computer systems or through those social
connections
yeah thanks that have a really hard time
imagining the job of a security expert
today and
that makes it makes it a lot clearer
that's great yeah it's uh
there's a lot of different attack
vectors out there and that's part of the
challenge
we struggle to plug them all so it comes
down to
risk management it's like what are the
most likely ways for
attackers to get in and achieve their
objectives and we
focus our attention on those do you
think it's a security risk having
your information on these systems at all
and what happens if we have a dystopian
government
in 20 years time and they
retrospectively look through
all your data it's certainly the case
now in the uk they've just passed
an act where the the police can uh get
access to your data so facebook will
send them your data
and you need to have committed a fairly
serious crime for this so probably
terrorism or something like that but
they will get a dump of
everything you've ever done on facebook
and the extent of that dump
is quite it's quite significant it's not
just your photos and stuff like that
it's things that you've been looking at
and clicking on and so on is this
something we should be concerned about
because you can't really live off the
grid anymore you need to be on linkedin
just to be employable
yeah i would agree it is something to
worry about
let's face it the do you know what you
were doing
on thursday the 12th of february 2016.
you you can't remember can you but our
best i bet facebook knows what you're
doing
there'll be you know something that
you're doing around that time that maybe
you would have posted about
and it's it's a scary proposition
that our social media accounts our
digital accounts in general
are just our calendar on our mobile
phone
knows more about us than we know about
it us
ourselves because our memory is fragile
whereas a computer's memory will well
last as
as long as it can but who are you though
this is what worries me talking about
because
i resent this idea that people are
morally
responsible for things that they did 20
years ago or so
and as you say there's this panopticon
now where every single action that you
take
is monitored and recorded and
the argument for privacy is that you
need to have a privacy
away from the judgmental lies of others
to discover yourself because remember we
said
self-determination is important you need
to discover yourself and figure out
who you are and you need to have the
autonomy and freedom to change who you
are
and you shouldn't necessarily be judged
for who you were
true but that's a societal challenge
nothing to do with
technology well i think the technology
makes it very difficult to
have the freedom of self-determination
if you have the threat of
retroactive judgment later true but
again that's society that is laying down
that judgment on past you from 20 years
ago
and sure the the technology doesn't
contain the the context around that
thing that you clicked on or
that post that you made that then means
that judgment doesn't have the full
amount of information around it
but again that's that's not necessarily
down to the technology that's society i
think
yeah interesting conversation for sure
and
i think it'll be really cool to see
where we evolve as
a civilization in terms of dealing with
this because
it seems to me like it's not on a
sustainable path
and that i'm going to have to adapt
culturally because it doesn't seem like
there's
any way that the technology itself is
going to the genie is going to be put
back in the bottle so to speak
so we're going to need to develop the
tools as a culture to
to deal with this and i i think the
point you bring up of
this uh tendency to cast judgment on
people for what they did 20 years ago
when
there's just a totally different set of
cultural norms
is like absurd it's convenient in the
political realm
it's also a little bit scary because now
we're all susceptible to this
and one of my favorite things to do if
i'm
so locally some of the bars show like
these old tv shows from the
90s american gladiators and stuff it's
like this silly show i don't know if
you've ever seen it
but it's like early 90s these guys with
big hair and muscles doing like
these silly competitions and then to
take
their name and google it to see whatever
happened to that person
and then you just un uncover these
marvelous stories of this amazing
like whether tragic or heroic has
happened and it's just crazy that
back then no one could have anticipated
the world
that was to come before them and then
they're making these decisions to put
themselves in the public eye
that they could have never imagined the
consequences of those decisions because
the world around them has changed
so much so the fact that this guy was on
this silly game show
in the early 90s and
now that's triggered something to
someone years and years later that can
now
has the incentive for whatever silly
reason to like
dig up their life story and see the
crimes they committed and they went to
prison and all this stuff it's
it's just weird that society has changed
and
your decisions have already been locked
in and you have no chance to go back
and change them and it has unpredictable
consequences
in the future i know it's something that
worries me greatly that because the
politicians we have now are so
incredibly bland because they have to be
morally
squeaky clean and now there is this idea
that not only are you responsible for
things you did 20 years ago that they
seem to be moving the goal post so now
if you are even photographed with
someone who has morally abhorrent views
then you are
adjacent to someone who has those
morally abhorrent views
and you it it's it's almost getting
ridiculous and
because andy and i talk about ethical
frameworks at work and
we do recognize that the the discourse
around
what's right and what's what's wrong is
always changing and
we joke that barack obama might have his
statue torn down in 20 years time
because
he wasn't a vegan so all we can do is is
record
what we think is good now and who said
what when
but the thought of being accountable for
things that we do now
to such a high level of precision it's
like that episode of black mirror where
they have the memory recorder
and that's just the antithesis of
privacy
yeah this like uh ultra puritanism
of morality it's just not gonna be able
to last because nobody can
basically clear this bar this standard
so it has to collapse
it's just a question of what's going to
happen before it does and when is that
going to be because
there's just no way that anybody can be
held up to that level of scrutiny
and pass
yeah and ironically many of these people
are moral relativists as well so they
it's a very high bar of reality but it's
one which is
only valid and constructed in this
particular society that we live in
isn't you getting into a big discussion
about free speech and
shouldn't you let like dumb people just
say their dumb things because then
everyone sees that
this is clearly a dumb thing i don't
know i i'm on the side of letting things
stand
and i find this really fascinating
because this kind of
comes almost full circle to the
conversation that we're having about
social media companies in general right
in terms of
how much accountability does a social
media platform have for the
uh comments that people make on it
should facebook or youtube or twitter
where do they draw the line in terms of
what comments are acceptable or not
are they fostering these types of
abhorrence opinions or behaviors
and i guess there's probably different
levels here in terms of
there's the completely apathetic
perspective
or the completely apathetic behavior of
we're just going to have a platform and
people can do what they want
and we'll just trust them not to do
mean things or bad things then there's
the okay i guess i need to
maybe be a bit more proactive and
actually go actively out the way to
channel discussions
in a in a way that is
more acceptable but it comes down to
that challenge of how do you define
acceptability
and that line is a gray fuzzy line all
of us have a different perspective on
where that line is
and also how fuzzy that line is is it a
very definite
it's either right or wrong or is it
right wrong or
kind of right or wrong but maybe okay in
some situations
it's it's again i think it comes back to
more of a societal problem
than a technology problem per se the
social media companies actually have a
legal problem in this case
they have a definite legal problem but
even the individual because here's the
practical problem
then it's well you deleted this other
thing so
you must agree with this thing since you
didn't delete it right so this is
and i'm not right it's like
i feel deleting some things is the worst
option
deleting all the things is the second
worst option and the best option still
seems to be to me to be to let
everything stand and just
be there for everyone to see
youtube has i i forget the numbers but
some crazy like
billion minutes of video uploaded every
day or something
insane it's like and it's a team of i
don't know
tens of thousands of people or something
or much less it's like how could you
possibly
solve this problem without using machine
learning or something like that
which then gets us right back to where
we started which is like
the bias in these algorithms the choices
that have to be codified
to make it to go not go decision because
you have to have like labels and then
it's wrong and do you want
explainability and then you want to
regulate these it's just
a big mess and it's always been that way
and now maybe this technology has just
made it easier or applying to a
different group of people that maybe it
didn't apply to before or something like
that
i think going back to the technology
force multiplayer points yeah yeah
it then allows a a disagreement between
two groups to
grow at a rapid pace far quicker than it
would have done in
the times of long ago that that impact
is suddenly massively increased
gentlemen it's been a fantastic episode
thank you so much for joining us this
week hey it has been
a great discussion it's clearly so much
more to talk about yet uh
never enough time indeed well as i said
at the beginning this is the the first
in a three-part series
on this issue we've covered a lot of
ground today
[Music]
awesome thank you guys
guys nice to meet you guys
thank you bye